nintendo have revealed the release date
for the legend of zelda breath of the
wild as well as info about the games
special editions and story alongside a
brand new trailer march three is the
date you'll want to pencil in your
calendars as breath of the wild will
launch on both the switch and the wii u
of that day the new game trailer gave us
our first glimpse of Link's main
antagonist in the new game calamity
Gannon described as a primal evil that
is endured over the ages link is shown
interacting with a variety of characters
are taking on massive beasties and
exploring a whole host of different
environments if that all looks pretty
sweet to you you might want to know
about the breath of the wild bundles you
can get your hands on the 100-dollar
special edition includes a nintendo
switched shaker slate carrying piece of
the soundtrack a shaker I collectible
coin a relic of Hyrule calamity Gannon
tapestry and where the Warren map and
the game are all in a special edition
box if you want to up the ante the 130
dollar master edition gets you all that
plus a swanky master sword statue and a
collectible box that's everything we've
got for you at the moment but be sure to
pop back for new updates and everything
else that matters in gaming
you